ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من موسكو كاتيا طعمه
مراسلات العربيه وممتياب حذيفه عادل مراسل
العربيه سابدا معك حذيفه واخر التطورات
بحادثه سقوط مروحيات وزير الداخليه
الاوكراني الى ماذا افضت التحقيقات
الرسميه حتى الساعه
مساء الخير
بعد تكهنات كثيره وحديث في القنوات
الاوكرانيه وفي مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
الاوكرانيه حول ما اذا ما كان هذه حادثه
ام بفعل طبعا
الرئيسكي قبل قليل في المنتدى الاقتصاد
العالمي في ذا فويس عبر مداخل عبر
الانترنت قال بشكل واضح ان هذه الحادثه او
مقتل همم وزير الداخليه من ستيرسكي هذه
ليست بحادثه قال هذه حرب حقيقيه والحرب
يمكن ادارتها بطرق عده في اشاره الى ان
هذه الحادثه كانت مدبره طبعا الحديث حول
هذه الحادثه الجهاز الامن الوطني فتح
تحقيق حول هذه الحادثه وقال انه لديه همم
ثلاثه همم يعني همم يبحث في ثلاثه اتجاهات
اولا هو ان يكون هذه همم فعلا الاحوال
الجويه او حادثه عابره او ان يكون هذا
بتخريب او بفعل فاعل طبعا ايضا نفذ اداره
الطوارئ ان يكون هنالك يعني ما نشرت يقول
بشكل واضح انه لم يكن هناك استهداف في
الجو بعد عن انه لا لم يكن هنالك حريق في
هذه المروحيه في الجو وانما الحريق حدث
بعد
هذه المروحيه طبعا
ايضا تحقق امن الدوله يحقق في مساله
البروتوكول ومساله يعني خرق القواعد في
مثل هذه الظروف خاصه في ظروف الحرب طبعا
اداره الطوارئ قالت ان هذه المروحيه هي
مروحيه الطوارئ وهذه المروحيه والطاقم
عملوا في ظروف جويه صعبه جدا
واستطاعوا ان
يجلوا عدد من المواطنين في ظروف مختلفه هم
جاهزين للعمليات الصعبه وقد كانوا جاهزين
في هذه المهمه لاداء المهمه في ظروف صعبه
هذا ايضا يحيي ويستبعد عمليه هذه الطائره
قد سقط نتيجه حادث عربي لان الطائره طبعا
هي اصلا طائره همم
هذا من جانبي طبعا ب- ااا اليوم ايضا او
مجلس الوزراء الاوكراني اتخذ القرار
بتعيين يهركل الملكو همم مدير الشرطه
الوطنيه همم نائب لوزير الداخليه وتم
تكليفه من قبل مجلس الوزراء بالتشاور مع
البرلمان طبعا بتكلفه بي مهام وزير
الداخليه والى ان يتم تعيينه وزير
للداخليه جديد وهذا الامر يتم طبعا عمره
همم بعض الاليات بتشاور مع البرلمان همم
طبعا همم اختلف تماما من نشرته الرسميه
الان لدينا 14 قتيلا بينهم طفل واحد
وهنالك ما يقرب من جريحا ولكن كبيره
الاطباء في المستشفى التي نقل اليه الجرح
قال ان لديه خمسه من الجرح في حاله حر جدا
بينهم ثلاثه اطفال في حاله حرجه وشخصان
بالغين همم في حاله حرجه لديهم 30% جروح
في الجسم بما فيها جروح في الجهاز التنفسي
همم من عندك حذيفه سانتقل الى كاتا كات هل
هناك اي تعليق او موقف في موسكو حول هذه
الحادثه وايضا يعني على المقلب الاخر هناك
حرب كلاميه بين موسكو وبين الغرب موضوع
التسليح بموضوع طول وامد الحرب كل اجواء
من هناك معك
مرحبا
لم يتم التعليق من جانب روسيا على هذه
الحادثه فقد تناولتها وسائل الاعلام روسيه
طبعا هذا من جانب امام جانب اخر طبعا
بالنسبه لتسليح الذي تنوي او تنوي الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهو عشان التزويد به
اوكرانيا روسي ميرارا كانت قد تحدثت انها
همم طبعا همم هذا التزويد الدائم وهذا
الزخم بكميات الاسلحه هو سيطل فقط من
العمليه العمليه العسكريه واليوم كان وزير
الخارجيه روسي رجال ظروف قد علق خلال
المؤتمر الصحفي الموسع الذي عقده لنتائج
دبلوماسيه الروسيه ان اا واشنطن طبعا همم
هي تسع لتقويد روسيا من خلال باستخدامه او
باستغلال اوكرانيا ومن خلال تزويدها
بالاسلحه تطيل العمليه العسكريه هناك وهي
تقضي على الشعب الاوكراني بنفسه وليس فقط
روسيا طبعا تاكيدات الرئيس الروسي اليوم
جاءت همم
بان رو ستستمر في هذه العمليه العسكريه
وانها بالتاكيد ستنتصر فيها على الرغم من
التزويد الدائم للدول الغربيه ولواشنطن
بالاسلحه المتنوعه لاوكرانيا ليل نعم شكرا
لكما مراسلي العربيه كاتيا طعمه من موسكو
وحذيفه عادل من كياس